what is the status are you getting
married yeah look I just find it's
easier to not talk about with personal
life because usually I say the wrong
thing so ends up just complicating
things more liam hemsworth staying
tight-lipped about Miley Cyrus to ET on
Friday but he does tell us this
everyone's happy I'm happy you guys are
hypothetically speaking at everyone's
wedding everyone's happy so if we are
let's say planning a wedding anytime
soon
our sailboats gonna be involved or we're
talking destination wedding summer
winter I don't know not getting out of
yeah you're not gonna get nothing I feel
like it's just easier on everyone if we
keep the puzzle Liam might be staying
quiet but he and Miley do often post
about their pets on Instagram she helped
her man rescue this pup last year Dora
Dora yeah everywhere the Explorer
brothers kids my brother's kids are a
big fan of the show so that was it was
definitely inspired by that and how many
dogs do you have now there's a few
they're all they're all rescues but
there's um there's a few on the house so
getting any more are you done no I'm
pretty much done for the moment dogs and
wedding-planning aside the 26 year olds
is busy he joined Land Rover and the Ben
Ainslie racing team in their quest to
bring America's Cup home to Britain they
haven't won a Cup in 165 years yeah I
didn't even realize that sailing had
been around that long
my job was was the six-man which is
basically you sit at the back of the
boat and just hang on to the net don't
get in anyone's way
after being on on this this yacht and
and sort of witnessing it firsthand I
have so much more respect for these guys
and what they do it's just amazing the
coordination that they have and the
communication and just everything
they're doing I have no idea you know
what's going on but it's it's it's
incredible to watch
you